just to linger briefly and uh
the way
marxism is used as a term
on twitter
uh there's something called i'm sorry if
i'm using the terms incorrectly but uh
cultural marxism right
criticisms of universities
um
being infiltrated by cultural marxists
i'm not exactly sure i don't
pay close enough no no no but it's woke
it's yes there's a there's a kind of
woke ideology that i'm not exactly sure
right
it's not you what is the fundamental
text
who's the karl marx of wokeness uh
all i do know is that there are certain
characteristics
of
uh
woke ideology which is
hard lines are drawn between
the good guys and the bad guys
and uh
and basically everyone is a bad guy
except except the people that are very
loudly non-stop saying that they're the
good guy and that applies
for for inter for racism for sexism
for uh gender
um all the gender politics identity
politics all that kind of stuff is there
is there any parallels between
marxian economics and marxist ideology
and whatever is being called marxism on
twitter
no not much
mostly marx you have to
one of the consequences of the taboo
after world war ii
is that marxism like socialism and
communism become swear words it's like
calling somebody
well i won't
use bad language but
using a four-letter word to describe
somebody yes so instead of calling them
you know this or that you call them a
marxist in many circles this
is even worse than whatever other
adjective you might have used but it
doesn't have a particular meaning
that i can assess the closest you get is
your little list
it is somebody who is concerned about
uh
race and sex and
sexual orientation gender and all of
those things and wants there to be trans
gendered bathrooms and and that and i
don't like any of these people so i
slapped the word marxism or the phrase
cultural marxism because it isn't
marxism about getting more money or
controlling the industry or all those
things that dimly we know marxists
somehow are concerned about so this is
odd since they don't know much about
markham i've always been interested in
culture i mean
lukacs the man i mentioned to you before
gramsci that's what they're famous for
the analysis of what marxism
particularly has to say about culture
gramsci writes a great length about the
catholic church about
theater and painting in in italy and on
and on i mean
this is just ignorance talking they
don't know anything about that i don't
know what the names are
it's a it's a label
that summarizes kind of a shorthand i'm
against all of this i don't want to be
told
that there's ugly racism in this country
and it always has been or sexism or
um uh phobia against gay people whatever
it is that's agitating them
i mean marxism or socialism i mean it's
just
it's like socialism is the post office
it is
it is a mentality but i don't blame them
i mean it's childish
it's mean-spirited
but it comes out of the fact no one ever
sat them down and said you know here is
this tradition it's got these kinds of
things that people kind of share and
these big differences
look
an intelligent society
which this country is
could have and should have done that it
was fear
and a kind of terror that made them
behave in the way they did and we're now
seeing it having said that there is such
a thing as cultural marxism
what that is is
simply those marxists
who devoted themselves
to analyzing how it is
that a particular culture is on the one
hand shaped by capitalism and on the
other hand it becomes a condition for
capitalism to survive and grow in other
words how do we analyze the interaction
between
uh
the class struggle on the job
and attitude towards sexuality or
movements in music or whatever else
culture and there are
george lucach this hungarian great name
in there the greatest of all the names
antonio gramsci and a modern name just
died a couple of years ago a british
intellectual name stewart hall h-a-l-l
you want to if you want if if i were
teaching which i have done of course in
cultural marxism
those would be three
major
blocks on the syllabus
i would give you articles and books to
read of their stuff because it has been
so seminal in provoking many many others
so there is something to be said and
understood about the kind of culture
that capitalism creates and the kind of
culture that enables capitalism yes and
marxists are particularly those who like
to look at that interaction in other
words they're interested in how
capitalism shapes culture and how
culture shapes capitalism there's
another name i forgot
stuart hall is british
gramsci is italian lucas is hungarian
the german is walter benjamin
b-e-n-j-a-m-i-n
he was a member of the frankfurt school
which is a huge school of marxism that
developed in frankfurt germany and that
has a lot of people many of whom were
interested in cultural questions it was
a bit of a reaction against
the narrow marxism that was so focused
on economics and politics there were
people who said you're leaving out
very important parts of modern society
that are shaping the economy as much as
they are shaped by it and it was that
impetus to open marxism to be more
inclusive in what it deemed to be
important to understand that this cult
and they call themselves cultural
marxists but they had a completely
different meaning from this this is just
uh
you know just bad-mouthing that's all
you